c'était entre 13h30 et 14h je venais de
manger puis les gens de faire quelques
courses
après le boulot en fait je suis allé au
carrefour un carrefour city qui est dans
la rue michel-ange et puis quand je suis
revenu c'est-à-dire j'arrivais en face
du bistrot et il ya un mec qui arrivait
de la rue par la voix qui arrivait au
bistrot et en fait j'ai vu qu'il avait
un flingue qui tenait dans le dos avec
sa main droite
et en plus il il essayait un peu le
cacher mais en fait le monde le voyait
bien le flingue sur le coup j'ai
remarqué et je me disais c'est pas
possible que c'est un mec bien
cependant c'est un mec qui a un pistolet
je suis gaulliste les plastiques comme
moi j'avais quand j'étais petit ça c'est
hyper content dires sa meilleure course
est tellement improbable c'est pour
incroyable de voir un mec avec un
flingue dans la rue qu'on veut pas
imaginer que ça un vrai et donc je les
ai vu s'avancer il est allé devant le
bistrot il a aidé à aller dans l'autre
eu donc je crois que c'est devant
l'hôpital
ça s'est passé et est donc là j'ai
entendu trois coups de feu je me dis
c'est sérieux surtout quand j'ai vu les
gens qui le voyaient moi j'ai pas vu
comment il a tiré tout ça parce que
j'étais déjà dans la rue de maryse et
lui il était plus dans la rue
michel-ange et quand j'ai entendu trois
coups de feu comme un coup de tonnerre
ça m'a fait stresser et donc j'ai couru
j'ai pas réfléchi j'ai couru je me suis
dit s'il commence si c'est un attentat
avec le mec pense à tirer sur les gens
je suis mal barré et donc j'ai couru
jusqu'à mon boulot et je reste et je
restais là bas
[Musique]
ouais alors c'était un mec qui avait
gelé vu de dos donc c'est assez
compliqué de le décrire mais c'est un
mec qui avait plutôt qu'ils étaient
plutôt dégarni au niveau des cheveux il
avait une grosse veste d'hiver
il faisait à peu près peut-être ma
taille peut-être à peine plus grands moi
je dirais la quarantaine mais après
voilà c'est toujours compliqué quand on
a vu juste un mec de dos
[Musique]
voilà ces grosses vestes d'hiver et qui
nombreuses capuches impression cette
personne ouais alors c'est pour ça que
après quand je suis quand j'ai repris
mes esprits on va dire que j'étais plus
stressée je me suis dit que ça doit être
un règlement de comptes parce que sinon
ils auraient tiré sur tout le monde en
fait après apparemment de ce que j'ai lu
dans les journaux c'est un médecin c'est
un peu bizarre son règlement de comptes
donc je pense qu'il était plutôt sûr de
nuit quoi ouais ouais je pense qu'ils
oui je pense qu'ils étaient déterminés
oui oui non parce que quand pile au
moment où je les ai vu disparaître
gentilly trois coups de feu je me suis
dit c'est bon quoi il ya quelqu'un qui a
dû être mort où il se passe quelque
chose il vous l'avez vu ensuite prendre
la fuite
non alors après j'ai rien mais parce que
une fois que j'ai entendu les coups de
feu
j'ai commencé j'ai commencé un peu à
regarder les gens autour de moi et j'ai
couru
donc du coup j'ai vraiment pas cherché à
savoir où ils allaient tout ça sachant
que le voyait déjà plus quand il a tiré
ouais ouais ouais en fait il ya quand
même le temps que les gens se rendent
compte de ce qui se passe donc c'est à
dire moi j'ai commencé à courir il y
avait dirais tous les gens dans la rue
qui savaient pas vraiment c'était des
pétards ou pas qui était là qu'est ce
qui se passe tout ça et c'est les gens
qui ont vu que j'ai vu courir aussi donc
ça a été la panique en il a fallu un
petit peu de temps mais oui ça a été la
panique
bah il ya eu un premier coup de feu et
ensuite de coups de feu je croyais à
duarte deux ou trois coups de feu donc
je pense qu'il a dû tirer sur les
personnes sur qui voulait tirer et puis
il s'est barré tout de suite quoi c'est
pour ça que je pense que ça doit être un
règlement de comptes ou alors il va en
vouloir à quelqu'un en particulier parce
que il est arrivé il a vu les deux
personnes qui devaient connaître
peut-être et il a tiré quoi j'ai pas
quelques quelques dizaines et de
dizaines de mètres